si je vous dis allezy va on va faire la
teuf vous comprenez rien du
tout va on va faire la teuf vous
comprenez pas tellement non et pourtant
le C frran ou le français pour les
puristes est bien une composante de la
langue française si tu viens pas ici
tutit bouffon j'attrape ta gueule et je
la marave autrement dit si vous ne vous
présentez pas immédiatement devant moi
monsieur ma réaction risque d'être
violente et incontrôlée c'est beaucoup
plus long et surtout moins efficace par
exemple si vous vous allez dans la cour
vous vous parlez par exemple du langage
soutenu à quelqu'un et ben il va vous
prendre pour un amif je pense que la
langue française c'est une tellement
belle langue on va pas la laisser
s'appauvrir tout change et effectivement
les les mots changent les phrases
changent les tout change donc c'est bien
que la la langue qui est le véhicule le
plus important dans la vie change aussi
çaap le français est une langue aimée et
tant qu'elle sera une langue aimée et
aimable il ne peut pas lui arriver de
grave malheur